hello everyone Karen warden with phone
courage the radio show I'm here with the
filmmakers of bold native Casey soo han
and Dennis finally and we just finished
our interview and there's a couple
questions we didn't get to ask I know
you sold out five cities of screenings
of bold native I believe that right
Portland la Portland la Seattle Eric DC
um and we've also done screenings in the
UK and in Belgium and we're setting up
more screenings now we have one in San
Francisco coming up November eighteenth
with John Robbins John Oh John Robbins
and activist trans Connery will be there
to speak so yeah we're setting up
college screenings right now and some
more cities probably but you know we've
been basically doing event screenings
where we attend and we try to have
speakers there from the local community
whether it be Farm Sanctuary people or
authors like John and it's been great i
mean one thing that's made it possible
is the new social media you know
applications we couldn't be doing what
we're doing without facebook like
facebook has been amazing to connect
with people who are passionate about the
film or the um you know animal rights in
these groups are in these cities I'm
like they have really helped publicize
the film places well they're also
inviting the film there you know I think
we have to go through emails it's part
of the next self distribution strategy
is engaging people to get really
proactive about we want the film here in
Minnesota we want the film here in Texas
or wherever they happen to be and we
have I think about like 400 emails that
we have to answer we have a combatant
but we will we had Serena Moines Iowa
and that was at an unconventional
screening place was a place it's a bar
but also does advance and those concerts
and screenings and
that sort of stuff so and that was
totally set up organized by a guy named
Adam who was passionate about seeing the
film and showing to other people and so
he set it up he got the screening he
publicized it and I think there was like
50 people here are 60 people in Des
Moines that came out to see the movie
and so like we did that as a fundraiser
for a couple of activists who were being
targeted by the legal system and so you
know I think that kind of thing is
something we want to do more of and
something that like we're able to do
because we do have like this core
audience it's passionate about the film
I think in terms of like we've been self
distributing the movie and that's our
goal with this is the self distributed
and it's challenging and it's definitely
made possible by the fact that we're
what you know we're film that does have
a core audience it doesn't mean that's
our only audience you know we can expand
beyond that core audience people who are
interested in animal rights but those
are the people who have been helpful in
getting it into theaters getting it into
like screening venues and then hopefully
reaching out to other people whenever
you make a film you know like unless you
have an audience you might as well like
look in the mirror you know gives it
your navel we were talking about
navel-gazing the other day like you want
to be having a conversation with
somebody outside of you know the team
that made the film and I forgot where I
was going with this how's it going to
say I don't know just know your audience
I think you know something to know from
the beginning when you're visioning the
film you know when you're thinking about
what is this film I'm going to you
talked about on you mentioned the
screening of like paradise recovered
which a film by storm would and Andy red
wine and like that's a film that is
about you know religious cults and about
finding one's faith and so they knew
that there was a core audience of people
who are interested in religious films
but maybe haven't seen a film that
challenges some ideas you know in the
way that they wanted to see and so they
may not talking you know I'm a friend of
Andy's and talking with her about the
film she was always conscious of like
who
interested in it you know and I think
that that's something that if you're
going to pursue a self distribution
route I don't know that they are they
may find contributor they're doing
festivals now but even you should always
assume that you may have to if you're
making a film on your own because you
never know that some there's never going
to be that knight in shining armor it's
going to come and take your film you
shouldn't assume that's going to happen
in my you never know and so figuring out
who your audience is and how you're
going to connect with them like
emotionally and get people passionate
about the film I think it's got to be
part of the design of the film yeah and
I remember my point my point was that
distribution isn't always a good thing
either you know we had a film called
rock the bells that got picked up by
Warner Brothers and you would think oh
great thing like Warner Brothers is
going to have the resources to get this
film about the wu-tang clan right to the
wu-tang audience and they were they got
caught up in Batman or whatever the heck
else they were distributing that year
and we were this little movie that got
lost and there are some hardcore fans
who have found it and we're constantly
meeting people who have seen the film
and really liked it but you know you're
not making a film especially a film like
bold native that is about issues just
for yourself and a small group of people
you want it to find an audience so even
going into this I think we knew that
self distribution was something we were
interested in doing because we had had
that experience with Warner Brothers
we've just got lost and we and that's
the worst thing that can happen to your
movie is it a good loss and it doesn't
find its audience so engaging with
people directly is really important and
keeping control of it is really really
important I think and it may take a
little bit longer because you in a small
group of people are setting up this
college tour trying to figure out how to
connect with those people who are
engaging you from other cities and
saying we want the movie here so it
might take a year or six months or
whatever to actually get the film to
them but if you control it you'll be
able to actually do that so that was
actually something to us from the get-go
that was important is that we maintain
control we distributed ourselves and we
figure it out we we had a really great
experience of distribution we continue
with the project that we do called the
Sanford Meisner master class and it's
basically this DVD we worked with the
sanford meisner estate on which is eight
hours of sanford meisner teaching a
master class in 1980 that they just had
the footage and they needed it put
together so we edited together and we
distribute it for them just through our
website Meisner DVD calm and it
continues to go out to people every week
we send out copies every week and in
finding people because it's very
specifically about something and if
somebody types in sanford meisner in
google it will take them to the Meisner
DVD com website and there'll be a google
ad on the side and so there's people
looking for it and it doesn't really
exist and that's the same thing with
this people looking for something about
animal liberation and animal rights and
hey there's lots of documentaries but I
can watch a fiction film to and learn
about this thing that I'm interested in
I think this is there was a you know I
think takedown Falls is a great example
this as well like this is a film about a
subculture and I think that's a smart
thing to do as you're thinking about
making a film is to say what's the
subculture or culture that I'm
interested in that maybe how's it has
story told about it and because you can
tell any story there's only seven or
whatever right you know there's like
these basic numbers of the stories you
can tell that within any culture so
there's a culture you're interested in
that hasn't had like its stories told
you know we weren't with bull nado we
were just we weren't thinking about this
because we came up with this idea so
many years ago but now as we're thinking
about new projects we're definitely
thinking like before you make it who is
the audience you know who are the people
that haven't had their story told that
that are going to be the ones who are
going to be your partners with this film
because that's basically what they are
they're the ones who are helping get the
word out and if you can make a film that
somebody types into Google you know
whatever they're passionate about and
you can reach them immediately for like
sixty cents a click or whatever it is
you know a google adwords then you know
that's an amazing tool and something
that i think should be in the
consciousness of storytellers remember i
begin